[Music]
from even the greatest of horrors
irony is seldom absent sometimes
it enters directly into the composition
of the events
while sometimes it relates only to their
fortuitous position
among persons and places the latter sort
is splendidly exemplified by a case in
the ancient city of providence
where in the late 40s edgar allan poe
used to sojourn often
during his unsuccessful wooing of the
gifted poetist mrs whitman
poe generally stopped at the mansion
house in benefit street
the renamed golden ball inn whose roof
has sheltered washington
jefferson and lafayette and his favorite
walk led northward
along the same street to mrs whitman's
home and the neighboring hillside
churchyard of st
john's whose hidden expanse of 18th
century gravestones
had for him a peculiar fascination
now the irony is this in this walk
so many times repeated the world's
greatest master of the terrible and the
bizarre
was obliged to pass a particular house
on the eastern side of the street
a dingy antiquated structure perched on
the abruptly rising side hill
with a great unkempt yard dating from a
time when the region was partly open
country it does not appear that he ever
wrote or spoke of it
nor is there any evidence that he even
noticed it
and yet that house to the two persons in
possession of certain information
equals or outranks in horror the wildest
fantasy of the genius
who so often passed it unknowingly and
stands starkly leering as a symbol
of all that is unutterably hideous
the house was and for that matter still
is
of a kind to attract the attention of
the curious
originally a farm or semi-farm building
it followed the average new england
colonial lines of the middle 18th
century
the prosperous peaked roof sort with two
stories in dormerless attic
and with a georgian doorway and interior
paneling dictated by the progress of
taste at that time
it faced south with one gable end buried
to the lower windows in the eastward
rising hill
and the other exposed to the foundations
toward the street
its construction over a century and a
half ago
had followed the grading and
straightening of the road and that a
special vicinity
for benefit street at first called
backstreet
was laid out as a lane winding amongst
the graveyards of the first settlers
and it straightened only when the
removal of the bodies to the north
burial ground
made it decently possible to cut through
the old family plots
at the start the western wall had lain
some 20 feet up
a precipitous lawn from the roadway but
a widening of the street
at about the time of the revolution
sheared off most of the intervening
space
exposing the foundation so that a brick
basement wall had to be made
giving the deep seller a street frontage
with door and one window above ground
close to the new line of public travel
when the sidewalk was laid out a century
ago
the last of the intervening space was
removed
and poe in his walks must have seen only
a sheer ascent of dull grey brick flush
with the sidewalk
and surmounted at a height of 10 feet by
the antique shingled bulk of the house
proper
the farm-like ground extended back very
deeply up the hill
almost to wheaton street the space south
of the house
a budding on benefit street was of
course greatly above the existing
sidewalk level
forming a terrace bounded by a high bank
wall of damp mossy stone
pierced by a steep flight of narrow
steps which led inward between
canyon-like surfaces
to the upper region of mangy lawn roomy
brick walls
and neglected gardens whose dismantled
cement urns
rusted kettles fallen from tripods of
naughty sticks
and similar paraphernalia set off the
weather-beaten front door with its
broken fan light
rotting ionic plasters and wormy
triangular pediment
what i heard in my youth about the
shunned house was merely that people
died there in alarmingly great numbers
that i was told was why the original
owners had moved out some 20 years after
building the place
it was plainly unhealthy perhaps because
of the dampness and fungus growths in
the cellar
the general sickish smell the drafts of
the hallways
or the quality of the well and pump
water
these things were bad enough and these
were all that gained belief among the
persons whom i knew
only the notebooks of my antiquarian
uncle dr elijah whipple
revealed to me at length the darker
vaguer surmises
which formed an undercurrent of folklore
among old-time servants and humble folk
surmises which never traveled far and
which were largely forgotten
when providence grew to be a metropolis
with a shifting modern population
the general fact is that the house was
never regarded by the solid part of the
community
as in any real sense haunted
there were no widespread tales of
rattling chains
cold currents of air extinguished lights
or faces at the window extremists
sometimes said that the house was
unlucky but that is as far as even they
went
what was really beyond dispute is that a
frightful proportion of persons died
there
or more accurately had died there since
after some peculiar happenings over 60
years ago
the building had become deserted through
the sheer impossibility of renting it
these persons were not all cut off
suddenly by any one cause
rather did it seem that their vitality
was insidiously sapped
so that each one died the sooner from
whatever tendency to weakness
he may have naturally had and those who
did not die
displayed in varying degree a type of
anemia
or consumption and sometimes a decline
of the mental faculties
which spoke ill for the salubriousness
of the building
neighboring houses that must be added
seemed entirely free from the noxious
quality
this much i knew before my insistent
questioning
led my uncle to show me the notes which
finally embarked us both on our hideous
investigation
in my childhood the shunned house was
vacant
with barren gnarled and terrible old
trees
long queerly pale grass and
nightmarishly misshapen weeds in the
high terraced yard
where birds never lingered we boys used
to overrun the place
and i can still recall my youthful
terror not only at the morbid
strangeness of this sinister vegetation
but at the eldritch atmosphere and odor
of the dilapidated
house whose unlocked front door was
often entered in quest of shutters
the small paned windows were largely
broken and a nameless air of desolation
hung around the precarious paneling
shaky interior shutters
peeling wallpaper falling plaster
rickety staircases
and such fragments of battered furniture
has still remained
the dust and cobwebs added their touch
of the fearful
and brave indeed was the boy who would
voluntarily ascend the ladder to the
attic
a vast raftered length lighted only by
small blinking windows and the gable
ends
and filled with a massive wreckage of
chests chairs and spinning wheels
which infinite years of deposit had
shrouded and festooned into monstrous
and hellish shapes
but after all the attic was not the most
terrible part of the house
it was the dank humid cellar which
somehow exerted the strongest
repulsion on us even though it was
wholly above ground on the street side
with only a thin door and window-pierced
brick wall
to separate it from the busy sidewalk we
scarcely knew whether to haunt it and
spectral fascination
or to shun it for the sake of our souls
and our sanity
for one thing the bad odor of the house
was strongest there
and for another thing we did not like
the white fungus growths
which occasionally sprang up in rainy
summer weather from the hard earth floor
those fungi grotesquely like the
vegetation in the yard outside
were truly horrible in their outlines
detestable parodies of toadstools and
indian pipes
whose like we had never seen in any
other situation
they rotted quickly and at one stage
became slightly phosphorescent
so that nocturnal passersby sometimes
spoke of which fires
glowing behind the broken panes of the
feeder-spreading windows
we never even in our wildest halloween
moods
visited this cellar by night but in some
of our daytime visits
could detect the phosphorescence
especially when the day was dark and wet
there was also a subtler thing we often
thought we detected
a very strange thing which was however
merely suggestive at most
i refer to a sort of cloudy whitish
pattern on the dirt floor
a vague shifting deposit of mold or
nighter which we sometimes thought we
could trace
amidst the sparse fungus growths near
the huge fireplace of the basement
kitchen
once in a while it struck us that this
patch
bore an uncanny resemblance to a
doubled-up human figure
though generally no such kinship existed
and often there was no whitish deposit
whatever
on a certain rainy afternoon when this
illusion seemed phenomenally strong
and when in addition i had fancied i
glimpsed a kind of thin
yellowish shimmering exhalation rising
from the nitrous pattern toward the
yawning fireplace
i spoke to my uncle about the matter he
smiled at this odd conceit
but it seemed that his smile was tinged
with reminiscence
later i heard that a similar notion
entered into some of the wild ancient
tales of the common folk a notion
likewise alluding to ghoulish
wolfish shapes taken by smoke from the
great chimney
and queer contours assumed by certain of
the sinuous tree roots
that thrust their way into the cellar
through the loose foundation stones
not till my adult years did my uncle set
before me
the notes and data which he had
collected concerning the shunned house
dr whipple was a sane conservative
physician of the old school
and for all his interest in the place
was not eager to encourage
young thoughts toward the abnormal his
own view
postulating simply a building and
location of markedly unsanitary
qualities
had nothing to do with abnormality but
he realized that the very
picturesqueness which aroused his own
interest
would in a boy's fanciful mind take on
all manner of gruesome imaginative
associations
the doctor was a bachelor a white-haired
clean-shaven
old-fashioned gentleman and a local
historian of note
who had often broken alliance with such
controversial guardians of tradition
as sydney s ryder and thomas w bicknell
he lived with one manservant in a
georgian homestead
with knocker and iron railed steps
balanced eerily on the steep ascent of
north court street
beside the ancient brick court and
colony house where his grandfather
a cousin of that celebrated
privateersman captain whipple
who burnt his majesty's armed schooner
gaspi in 1772
had voted in the legislature on may 4th
1776
for the independence of the rhode island
colony
around him in the damp low ceilinged
library with the musty white paneling
heavy carved over mantle and small paned
vine shaded windows
were the relics and records of his
ancient family
among which were many dubious allusions
to the shunned house
in benefit street that pest spot
lies not far distant for benefit runs
ledgewise
just above the courthouse along the
precipitous hill
of which the first settlement climbed
when
in the end my insistent pestering and
maturing years
evoked from my uncle the hoarded lore i
sought
there lay before me a strange enough
chronicle
long-winded statistical and drearily
genealogical as some of the matter was
there ran through it a continuous thread
of brooding tenacious horror
and preternatural malevolence which
impressed me even more than it
impressed the good doctor separate
events fitted together uncannily
and seemingly irrelevant details held
minds of hideous possibilities
a new and burning curiosity grew in me
compared to which my
boyish curiosity was feeble and encoed
the first revelation led to an
exhaustive research
and finally to that shuddering quest
which proved so disastrous to myself
and mine for at the last my uncle
insisted on joining the search i had
commenced
and after a certain night in that house
he did not come away with me
i am lonely without that gentle soul
whose long years were filled only with
honor
virtue good taste benevolence and
learning
i have reared a marble urn to his memory
in saint john's churchyard
the place that poe loved the hidden
grove of giant willows on the hill
where tombs and headstones huddle
quietly between the hoary bulk of the
church
and the houses and bank walls of benefit
street
the history of the house opening amidst
a maze of dates
revealed no trace of the sinister either
about its construction
or about the prosperous and honorable
family who built it
yet from the first a taint of calamity
soon increased to boating significance
was apparent my uncles carefully
compiled
record began with the building of the
structure in 1763
and followed the theme with an unusual
amount of detail
the shunned house it seems was first
inhabited by william harris
and his wife ruby dexter with their
children
alcana born in 1755 abigail
born in 1757 william jr
born in 1759 and ruth
born in 1761. harris was a substantial
merchant and seaman
in the west india trade connected with
the firm of obadiah brown and his
nephews
after brown's death in 1761 the new firm
of nicolas brown and company made him
master of the brig prudence
providence built of 120 tons thus
enabling him to erect the new homestead
he had desired
ever since his marriage the site he had
chosen
a recently straightened part of the new
and fashionable backstreet
which ran along the side of the hill
above crowded cheapside
was all that could be wished and the
building did justice to the location
it was the best that moderate means
could afford and harris hastened to move
in before the birth of a fifth child
which the family expected
that child a boy came in december
but was stillborn nor was any child to
be born alive
in that house for a century and a half
the next april sickness occurred among
the children
and abigail and ruth died before the
month was over
dr jobe ives diagnosed the trouble as
some infantile fever
though others declared it was more of a
mere wasting away or decline
it seemed in any event to be contagious
for hannah bowen one of the two servants
died of it
in the following june eli lydiason
the other servant constantly complained
of weakness
and would have returned to his father's
farm in rehoboth
before a sudden attachment for mahitabel
pierce
who was hired to succeed hannah he died
the next year
a sad year indeed since it marked the
death of william harris himself
and feebled as he was by the climate of
martinique
where his occupation had kept him for
considerable periods during the
preceding decade
the widowed robie harris never recovered
from the shock of her husband's death
and the passing of her firstborn elkena
two years later
was the final blow to her reason in 1768
she fell victim to a mild form of
insanity
and was thereafter confined to the upper
part of the house
her elder maiden sister mercy dexter
having moved in to take
charge of the family mercy was a plain
raw-boned woman
of great strength but her health visibly
declined from the time of her advent
she was greatly devoted to her
unfortunate sister
and had an especial affection for her
only surviving nephew william
who from a sturdy infant had become a
sickly spindling lad
in this year the serpent mahidabel died
and the other servant
preserved smith left without coherent
explanation
or at least with only some wild tales
and a complaint that he disliked the
smell of the place
for a time mercy could secure no more
help
since the seven deaths and case of
madness all occurring within five years
space
had begun to set in motion the body of
fireside rumor which later became so
bizarre
ultimately however she obtained new
servants from out of town
ann white a morose woman from that part
of north kingstown
now set off as the township of exeter
and a capable boston man
named zenith low it was ann white who
first gave
definite shape to the sinister idol talk
mercy should have known better than to
hire anyone from the nooseneck hill
country
for that remote bit of backwoods was
then as now
a seat of the most uncomfortable
superstitions
as lately as 1892 an exeter community
exhumed a dead body
and ceremoniously burnt its heart in
order to prevent certain
alleged visitations injurious to the
public health and peace
and one may imagine the point of view of
the same section
in 1768 anne's tongue was perniciously
active
and within a few months mercy discharged
her
filling her place with a faithful and
amiable amazon from newport
maria robbins meanwhile poor roby harris
in her madness gave voice to dreams and
imaginings of the most hideous sort
at times her screams became
insupportable
and for long periods she would utter
shrieking horrors
which necessitated her son's temporary
residence with his cousin
peleg harris in presbyterian lane near
the new college building
the boy would seem to improve after
these visits
and had mercy been as wise as she was
well-meaning
she would have let him live permanently
with peleg
just what mrs harris cried out in her
fits of violence
tradition hesitates to say or rather
present such extravagant accounts that
they nullify themselves through sheer
absurdity
certainly it sounds absurd to hear that
a woman educated only in the rudiments
of french
often shouted for hours in a coarse and
idiomatic form of that language
or that the same person alone and
guarded
complained wildly of a staring thing
which bit
and chewed at her in 1772
the servant zenis died and when mrs
harris heard of it
she laughed with a shocking delight
utterly foreign to her
the next year she herself died and was
laid to rest in the north burial ground
beside her husband upon the outbreak of
trouble with great britain in 1775
william harris despite his scant 16
years and feeble constitution
managed to enlist in the army of
observation under general greene
and from that time on enjoyed a steady
rise in health and prestige
in 1780 as a captain in the rhode island
forces
in new jersey under colonel angel he met
and married phoebe hatfield of
elizabethtown
whom he brought to providence upon his
honorable discharge in the following
year
the young soldier's return was not a
thing of unmitigated happiness
the house that is true was still in good
condition
and the street had been widened and
changed in name from backstreet to
benefit
street but mercy dexter's once robust
frame had undergone a sad and curious
decay
so that she was now a stooped and
pathetic figure with hollow voice and
disconcerting power
qualities shared to a singular degree by
the one remaining servant maria
in the autumn of 1782 phoebe harris gave
birth to a stillborn daughter
and on the 15th of the next may mercy
dexter took leave
of a useful austere and virtuous life
william harris at last thoroughly
convinced of the radically unhealthful
nature of his abode
now took steps toward quitting it and
closing it forever
securing temporary quarters for himself
and his wife
at the newly opened golden ball inn he
arranged for the building of a new and
finer house in westminster street
in the growing part of the town across
the great bridge
there in 1785 his son duty was born
and there the family dwelt till the
encroachments of commerce
drove them back across the river and
over the hill to angel street
in the newer east side residence
district where the late archer harris
built his sumptuous but hideous
french roofed mansion in 1876.
william and phoebe both succumbed to the
yellow fever epidemic of 1797
but duty was brought up by his cousin
rathbone harris
peleg's son rathbone was a practical man
and rented the benefit street house
despite william's wish to keep it vacant
he considered it an obligation to his
ward to make the most of all the boy's
property
nor did he concern himself with the
deaths and illnesses which caused so
many changes of tenants
or the steadily growing aversion with
which the house was generally regarded
it is likely that he felt only vexation
when in 1804
the town council ordered him to fumigate
the place with sulphur
tar and gum camphor on account of the
much-discussed deaths of four persons
presumably caused by the then
diminishing fever epidemic
they said the place had a febrile smell
duty himself thought little of the house
for he grew up to be a privateersman
and served with distinction on the
vigilant under captain cahoon
in the war of 1812. he returned unharmed
married in 1814 and became a father on
that memorable night of september 23
1815 when a great gale drove the waters
of the bay over half the town
and floated a tall sloop well up
westminster street
so that its masts almost tapped the
harris windows
in symbolic affirmation that the new boy
welcome
was a seaman's son welcome did not
survive his father
but lived to perish gloriously at
fredericksburg
in 1862 neither he nor his son archer
knew of the shunned house as other than
a nuisance
almost impossible to rent perhaps on
account of the mustiness and sickly odor
of unkempt old age
indeed it never was rented after a
series of deaths culminating in 1861
which the excitement of the war tended
to throw into obscurity
carrington harris last of the male line
knew it only as a deserted and somewhat
picturesque center of legend
until i told him my experience he had
meant to tear it down
and build an apartment house on the site
but after my account
decided to let it stand install plumbing
and rent it
nor has he yet had any difficulty in
obtaining tenants
the horror has gone
it may well be imagined how powerfully i
was affected by the annals of the
harrises
in this continuous record there seemed
to me to brood a persistent evil
beyond anything in nature as i had known
it and evil
clearly connected with the house and not
with the family
this impression was confirmed by my
uncle's less systematic array of
miscellaneous data
legends transcribed from servant gossip
cuttings from the papers
copies of death certificates by fellow
physicians and the like
all of this material i cannot hope to
give for my uncle was a tireless
antiquarian
and very deeply interested in the
shunned house but i may refer to several
dominant points which are
noticed by their recurrence through many
reports from diverse sources
for example the servant gossip was
practically unanimous
in attributing to the fungus and
malodorous cellar of the house
a vast supremacy and evil influence
there had been servants and white
especially
who would not use the cellar kitchen and
at least three well-defined legends bore
upon the queer quasi-human or diabolic
outlines
assumed by tree roots and patches of
mold in that region
these latter narratives interested me
profoundly on account of what i had seen
in my boyhood
but i felt that most of the significance
had in each case
been largely obscured by additions from
the common stock of local ghost lore
anne white with her exeter superstition
had promulgated the most extravagant
and at the same time most consistent
tale
alleging that there must lie buried
beneath the house one of those
vampires the dead who retain their
bodily form
and live on the blood or breath of the
living whose hideous legions send their
praying shapes or spirits abroad by
night
to destroy a vampire one must the
grandmothers say
exhume it and burn its heart or at least
drive a stake through that organ
and anne's dogged insistence on a search
under the cellar
had been prominent in bringing about her
discharge
her tales however commanded a wide
audience and were the more readily
accepted because the house indeed stood
on land once used for burial purposes
to me their interests depended less on
this circumstance
than on the peculiarly appropriate way
in which they dovetailed with certain
other things
the complaint of the departing servant
preserved smith
who had preceded anne and never heard of
her that something
sucked his breath at night the death
certificates of the fever victims of
1804
issued by dr chad hopkins and showing
the four deceased persons all
unaccountably lacking in blood and the
obscure passages of poor robie harris's
ravings
where she complained of the sharp teeth
of a glassy-eyed half-visible presence
free from unwarranted superstition
though i am
these things produced in me an odd
sensation
which was intensified by a pair of
widely separated newspaper cuttings
relating to deaths in the shunned house
one from the providence gazette
and country journal of april 12 1815
and the other from the daily transcript
in chronicle of october 27
1845 each of which detailed an
appallingly grisly circumstance whose
duplication was remarkable
it seems that in both instances the
dying person
in 1815 a gentle old lady named stafford
and in 1845 a school teacher of middle
age named elizir durfee
became transfigured in a horrible way
glaring glassily
and attempting to bite the throat of the
attending physician
even more puzzling though was the final
case which put an
end to the renting of the house a series
of anemia deaths
preceded by progressive madnesses
wherein the patient would craftily
attempt the lives of his relatives by
incisions in the neck or wrist
this was in 1860 and 1861
when my uncle had just begun his medical
practice
and before leaving for the front he
heard much of it from his elder
professional colleagues
the really inexplicable thing was the
way in which the victims
ignorant people for the ill-smelling and
widely shunned house could now be rented
to know
others would babel maledictions in
french
a language they could not possibly have
studied to any extent
it made one think of poor robey harris
nearly a century before
and so moved my uncle that he commenced
collecting historical data on the house
after listening sometimes subsequent to
his return from the war
to the firsthand account of doctors
chase and whitmarsh
indeed i could see that my uncle had
thought deeply on the subject
and that he was glad of my own interest
an open-minded and sympathetic interest
which enabled him to discuss with me
matters at which others would merely
have laughed
his fancy had not gone so far as mine
but he felt that the place was rare in
its imaginative potentialities
and worthy of note as an inspiration in
the field of the grotesque and macabre
for my part i was disposed to take the
whole subject with profound seriousness
and began at once not only to review the
evidence but to accumulate as much more
as i could
i talked with the elderly archer harris
then owner of the house
many times before his death in 1916
and obtained from him and his still
surviving maiden sister alice
an authentic corroboration of all the
family data my uncle had collected
when however i asked them what
connection with france or its language
the house could have
they confessed themselves as frankly
baffled and ignorant as i
archer knew nothing and all that miss
harris could say was that an old
illusion her grandfather
judy harris had heard of might have shed
a little light
the old seaman who had survived his son
welcome's death in battle
by two years had not himself known the
legend
but recalled that his earliest nurse the
ancient maria robbins
seemed darkly aware of something that
might have lent a weird significance to
the french raving of roby harris
which she had so often heard during the
last days of that hapless woman
maria had been at the shunned house from
1769
till the removal of the family in 1783
and had seen mercy dexter die once she
hinted to the child duty
of a somewhat peculiar circumstance and
mercy's last moments
but he had soon forgotten all about it
saved that it was something peculiar
the granddaughter moreover recalled even
this much with difficulty
she and her brother were not so much
interested in the house as was archer's
son
carrington the present owner with whom i
talked after my experience
having exhausted the harris family of
all the information it could furnish
i turned my attention to early town
records and deeds with the zeal more
penetrating than that which my uncle had
occasionally shown in the same work
what i wished was a comprehensive
history of the site from its very
settlement in 1636
or even before if any narragansett
indian legend could be unearthed to
supply the data
i found at the start that the land had
been part of the long strip of home lot
granted originally to john throckmorton
one of many similar strips beginning at
the town street beside the river
and extending up over the hill to a line
roughly corresponding with the modern
hope street
the throckmorton lot had later of course
been much subdivided
and i became very assiduous in tracing
that section
through which back or benefit street was
later run
it had as rumor indeed said ben the
throckmorton graveyard
but as i examined the records more
carefully i found that the graves had
all been transferred at an early date
to the north burial ground on the
pawtucket west road
then suddenly i came by a rare piece of
chance
since it was not in the main body of
records and might easily have been
missed
upon something which aroused my keenest
eagerness
fitting in as it did with several of the
queerest phases of the affair it was the
record of elise
in 1697 of a small tract of ground
to an etienne roulet and wife
at last the french element had appeared
that and another deeper element of
horror which the name conjured up from
the darkest recesses of my weird and
heterogeneous reading
and i feverishly studied the plating of
the locality as it had been before the
cutting through
and partial straightening of backstreet
between 1747 and 1758
i found what i had half expected that
where the shunned house now stood
the brules had laid out their graveyard
behind a one-story and attic cottage
and that no record of any transfer of
graves existed
the document indeed ended in much
confusion
and i was forced to ransack both the
rhode island historical society
and shepley library before i could find
a local door which the name of etienne
relay would unlock
in the end i did find something
something of such
vague but monstrous import that i set
about at once to examine the cellar of
the shunned house itself
with a new and excited minuteness the
relays it seemed had come in 1696 from
east greenwich
down the west shore of narragansett bay
they were huguenots from canoed
and had encountered much opposition
before the providence selectmen allowed
them to settle
in the town unpopularity had dogged them
in east greenwich whether they had come
in 1686
after the revocation of the edict of
nantes and rumor said that the cause of
dislike
extended beyond mere racial and national
prejudice
or the land disputes which involved
other french settlers with the english
and rivalries which not even governor
andros could quell
but there ardent protestantism too
ardent some whispered
and their evident distress when
virtually driven from the village down
the bay
had moved the sympathy of the town
fathers here the strangers had been
granted a haven
and the swarthy etienne roulet less apt
at agriculture
than at reading queer books and drawing
queer diagrams
was given a clerical post in the
warehouse that pardoned tilling gas
wharf
far south in town street there had
however been a riot of some sort later
on
perhaps 40 years later after old relay's
death
and no one seemed to hear of the family
after that
for a century and more it appeared the
relays had been well remembered and
frequently discussed as vivid incidents
and the quiet life of a new england
seaport
etienne's son paul a surly fellow whose
erratic conduct had probably provoked
the riot which wiped out the family
was particularly a source of speculation
and though providence never shared the
witchcraft panics of her puritan
neighbors
it was freely intimated by old wives
that his prayers were neither uttered at
the proper time
nor directed toward the proper object
all this had undoubtedly formed the
basis of the legend
known by old maria robbins what relation
it had to the french ravings of robie
harris and other inhabitants of the
shunned house
imagination or future discovery alone
could determine
i wondered how many of those who had
known the legends
realized that additional link with the
terrible which my wider reading had
given me
that ominous item in the annals of
morbid horror
which tells of the creature jacques
roulet of cowd
who in 1598 was condemned to death as a
demoniac
but afterwards saved from the stake by
the paris parliament
and shut in a madhouse he had been found
covered with blood and shreds of flesh
in a wood
shortly after the killing and rending of
a boy by a pair of wolves
one wolf was seen to lope away unhurt
surely a pretty hearthside tale with a
queer significance as to name and place
but i decided that the providence
gossips could not have generally known
of it
had they known the coincidence of names
would have brought some drastic and
frightened action
indeed might not its limited whispering
have precipitated the final riot
which erased the roules from the town
i now visited the accursed place with
increased frequency
studying the unwholesome vegetation of
the garden
examining all the walls of the building
and pouring over every inch of the
earthen cellar floor
finally with carrington harris's
permission i fitted a key to the disused
door
opening from the cellar directly upon
benefit street
preferring to have a more immediate
access to the outside world than the
dark stairs
ground floor hall and front door could
give
there where morbidity lurked most
thickly
i searched and poked during long
afternoons when the sunlight filtered in
through the cobwebbed above ground
windows
and a sense of security glowed from the
unlocked door
which placed me only a few feet from the
placid sidewalk outside
nothing new rewarded my efforts only the
same
depressing mustiness and faint
suggestions of noxious odors and nitrous
outlines on the floor and i fancy that
many pedestrians
must have watched me curiously through
the broken pains
at length upon a suggestion of my uncles
i decided to try the spot nocturnally
and one stormy midnight ran the beams of
an electric torch over the moldy floor
with its uncanny shapes and distorted
half phosphorescent fungi
the place had dispirited me curiously
that evening and i was almost prepared
when i saw
or thought i saw amidst the whitish
deposits
a particularly sharp definition of the
huddled form i had suspected from
boyhead
its clearness was astonishing and
unprecedented
and as i watched i seemed to see again
the thin yellowish shimmering exhalation
which had startled me on that rainy
afternoon so many years before
above the anthropomorphic patch of mold
by the fireplace it rose
a subtle sickish almost luminous vapor
which as it hung trembling in the
dampness seemed to develop
vague and shocking suggestions of form
gradually trailing off into
nebulous decay and passing up into the
blackness of the great chimney with a
feeter in its wake
it was truly horrible and the more so to
me because of what i knew of the spot
refusing to flee i watched it fade and
as i watched i felt that it was in turn
watching me greedily with eyes more
imaginable than visible
when i told my uncle about it he was
greatly aroused
and after a tense hour of reflection
arrived at a definite and drastic
decision
weighing in his mind the importance of
the matter and the significance of our
relation to it
he insisted that we both test and if
possible destroy
the horror of the house by a joint night
or nights of aggressive vigil
in that musty and fungus cursed cellar
on wednesday june 25th 1919
after a proper notification of
carrington harris which did not include
surmises as to what we expected to find
my uncle and i conveyed to the shunned
house two camp chairs and a folding camp
cot
together with some scientific mechanism
of greater weight and
intricacy these we placed in the cellar
during the day
screening the windows with paper and
planning to return in the evening for
our first vigil
we had locked the door from the seller
to the ground floor
and having a key to the outside cellar
door were prepared to leave our
expensive and delicate apparatus
which we had obtained secretly and at
great cost
as many days as our vigils might be
protracted
it was our design to sit up together
until very late
and then watch singly till dawn in two
hour stretches
myself first and then my companion the
inactive member
resting on the cot the natural
leadership with which my uncle procured
the instruments from the laboratories of
brown university and the cranston street
armory
and instinctively assumed direction of
our adventure was a marvelous commentary
on the potential vitality and resilience
of a man of 81.
a lie who whipple had lived according to
the hygienic laws he had preached as a
physician
and but for what happened later would be
here in full vigor today
only two persons suspected what did
happen carrington harris and myself
i had to tell harris because he owned
the house and deserved to know what had
gone out of it
then two we had spoken to him in advance
of our quest
and i felt after my uncle's going that
he would understand
and assist me in some vitally necessary
public explanations
he turned very pale but agreed to help
me and decided that it would now be safe
to rent the house
to declare that we were not nervous on
that rainy night of watching
would be an exaggeration both gross and
ridiculous
we were not as i have said in any sense
childishly superstitious
but scientific study and reflection had
taught us that the known universe of
three dimensions
embraces the merest fraction of the
whole cosmos of substance and energy
in this case an overwhelming
preponderance of evidence from numerous
authentic sources
pointed to the tenacious existence of
certain forces of great power
and so far as the human point of view is
concerned exceptional malignancy
to say that we actually believed in
vampires or werewolves
would be a carelessly inclusive
statement
rather must it be said that we were not
prepared to deny the
possibility of certain unfamiliar and
unclassified modifications
of vital force and attenuated matter
existing very infrequently in
three-dimensional space
because of its more intimate connection
with other spatial units
yet close enough to the boundary of our
own to furnish us
occasional manifestations which we for
lack of a proper vantage point
may never hope to understand in short it
seemed to my uncle and me
that an incontrovertible array of facts
pointed to some lingering
influence in the shunned house traceable
to one or another of the ill-favored
french settlers of two centuries before
and still operative through rare and
unknown laws of atomic and electronic
motion
that the family of roulet had possessed
an abnormal affinity for outer circles
of entity
dark spheres which for normal folk hold
only repulsion and terror
their recorded history seemed to prove
had not been the riots of those bygone
1730s set moving certain kinetic
patterns
in the morbid brain of one or more of
them notably the sinister
paul roulet which obscurely survived the
bodies murdered and buried by the mob
and continued to function in some
multiple-dimensioned space
along the original lines of force
determined by a frantic hatred of the
encroaching community
such a thing was surely not a physical
or biochemical impossibility in the
light of a newer science
which includes the theories of
relativity and intra-atomic action
one might easily imagine an alien
nucleus of substance or energy
formless or otherwise kept alive by
imperceptible or immaterial subtractions
from the life force or bodily tissue and
fluids of other and more palpably living
things
into which it penetrates and with whose
fabric it sometimes completely merges
itself
it might be actively hostile or it might
be dictated merely by blind motives of
self-preservation
in any case such a monster must of
necessity
be in our scheme of things an anomaly
and an intruder
whose extirpation forms a primary duty
with every man not an enemy to the
world's life health and sanity
what baffled us was our utter ignorance
of the aspect in which we might
encounter the thing
no sane person had ever seen it and few
had ever felt it definitely
it might be pure energy a form ethereal
and outside the realm of substance
or it might be partly material some
unknown and equivocal mass of plasticity
capable of changing at will to nebulous
approximations of the solid
liquid gaseous or tenuously unparticled
states
the anthropomorphic patch of mold on the
floor the form of the yellowish vapor
and the curvature of the tree roots and
some of the old tales
all argued at least a remote and
reminiscent connection with the human
shape
but how representative or permanent that
similarity
might be none could say with any kind of
certainty
we had devised two weapons to fight it a
large and specially fitted crooks tube
operated by powerful storage batteries
and provided with peculiar
screens and reflectors in case it proved
intangible
and opposable only by vigorously
destructive ether radiations
and a pair of military flamethrowers of
the sort used in the world war
in case it proved partly material and
susceptible of mechanical destruction
for like the superstitious exeter
rustics we were prepared to burn the
thing's heart out
if heart existed to burn all this
aggressive mechanism we set in the
cellar
and positions carefully arranged with
reference to the cot and chairs
and to the spot before the fireplace
where the mold had taken strange shapes
that suggestive patch by the way was
only faintly visible when we placed our
furniture and instruments
and when we returned that evening for
the actual vigil
for a moment i half doubted that i had
ever seen it in the more definitely
limbed form
but then i thought of the legends our
cellar vigil began at 10 pm
daylight saving time and as it continued
we found no promise of pertinent
developments
a weak filtered glow from the rain
harassed street lamps outside
and a feeble phosphorescence from the
detestable fungi within
showed the dripping stone of the walls
from which all traces of whitewash had
vanished
the dank fetid and mildew tainted hard
earth floor
with its obscene fungi the rotting
remains of what had been stools
chairs and tables and other more
shapeless furniture
the heavy planks and massive beams of
the ground floor overhead
the decrepit plank door leading to bins
and chambers beneath other parts of the
house
the crumbling stone staircase with
ruined wooden handrail
and the crude and cavernous fireplace of
blackened brick
where rusted iron fragments revealed the
past presence of hooks and irons
spit crane and a door to the dutch oven
these things
and our austere cotton camp chairs and
the heavy and intricate destructive
machinery we had brought
we had as in my own former explorations
left the door to the street unlocked so
that a direct and practical path of
escape might lie open
in case of manifestations beyond our
power to deal with
it was our idea that our continued
nocturnal presence would call forth
whatever malign entity lurked there
and that being prepared we could dispose
of the thing with one or the other of
our provided means
as soon as we had recognized and
observed it sufficiently
how long it might require to evoke and
extinguish the thing
we had no notion it occurred to us too
that our venture was far from safe
for in what strength the thing might
appear no one could tell
but we deemed the game worth the hazard
and embarked on it alone and
unhesitatingly
conscious that the seeking of outside
aid would only expose us to ridicule
and perhaps defeat our entire purpose
such was our frame of mind as we talked
far into the night till my uncle's
growing drowsiness made me remind him to
lie down for his two-hour sleep
something like fear chilled me as i sat
there in the small hours alone
i say alone for one who sits by a
sleeper is indeed alone
perhaps more alone than he can realize
my uncle breathed heavily his deep
inhalations and exhalations
accompanied by the rain outside and
punctuated by another nerve-wracking
sound of distant dripping water within
for the house was repulsively damp even
in dry weather
and in this storm positively swamp-like
i studied the loose antique masonry of
the walls and the fungus light and the
feeble rays which stole in from the
street through the screened window
and once when the noise and atmosphere
of the place seemed about to sicken me
i opened the door and looked up and down
the street feasting my eyes on familiar
sights and my nostrils on wholesome air
still nothing occurred to reward my
watching and i yawned repeatedly
fatigued getting the better of
apprehension
then the stirring of my uncle in his
sleep attracted my notice
he had turned restlessly on the cot
several times during the latter half of
the first hour
but now he was breathing with unusual
irregularity
occasionally heaving a sigh which held
more than a few of the qualities of a
choking moan
i turned my electric flashlight on him
and found his face
averted so rising and crossing to the
other side of the cot
i again flashed the light to see if he
seemed in any pain
what i saw unnerves me most surprisingly
considering its relative triviality it
must have been merely the association of
any odd circumstance with the sinister
nature of our
location and mission for surely the
circumstance was not in itself
frightful or unnatural it was merely
that my uncle's facial expression
disturbed no doubt by the strange dreams
which our situation prompted
betrayed considerable agitation and
seemed not at all characteristic of him
his habitual expression was one of
kindly and well-bred calm
whereas now a variety of emotions seemed
struggling within him
i think on the whole that it was this
variety which chiefly disturbed me
my uncle as he gasped and tossed in
increasing perturbation and with eyes
that had now started open
seemed not one but many men and
suggested a curious quality of alienage
from himself
all at once he commenced to mutter and i
did not like the look of his mouth and
teeth as he spoke
the words were at first
indistinguishable and then
with a tremendous start i recognized
something about them
which filled me with icy fear till i
recalled the breadth of my uncle's
education and the interminable
translations he had made
from anthropological and antiquarian
articles in the review de du monde
for the venerable elijah whipple was
muttering in french
and the few phrases i could distinguish
seemed connected with the darkest myths
he had ever adapted from the famous
paris magazine
suddenly a perspiration broke out on the
sleeper's forehead
and he leaped abruptly up half awake the
jumble of french
changed to a cry in english and the
horse voice shouted excitedly
my breath my breath then the awakening
became complete
and with a subsidence of facial
expression to the normal state
my uncle seized my hand and began to
relate a dream whose nucleus of
significance i could only surmise with a
kind of awe
he had he said floated off from a very
ordinary series of dream pictures
into a scene whose strangeness was
related to nothing he had ever read
it was of this world and yet not of it a
shadowy geometrical confusion
and which could be seen elements of
familiar things in most unfamiliar and
perturbing combinations
there was a suggestion of queerly
disordered pictures superimposed one
upon another
an arrangement in which the essentials
of time as well as of space
seemed dissolved and mixed in the most
illogical fashion
in this kaleidoscopic vortex of
phantasmal images
were occasional snapshots if one might
use the term
of singular clearness but unaccountable
heterogeneity
once my uncle thought he lay in a
carelessly dug open pit
with a crowd of angry faces framed by
straggling locks and three cornered hats
frowning down on him
again he seemed to be in the interior of
a house an old house apparently
but the details and inhabitants were
constantly changing
and he could never be certain of the
faces or the furniture
or even of the room itself since doors
and windows seemed in just as great a
state of flux as the presumably more
mobile objects
it was queer damnably queer and my uncle
spoke almost sheepishly
as if half expecting not to be believed
when he declared that of the strange
faces
many had unmistakably borne the features
of the harris family
and all the while there was a personal
sensation of choking
as if some pervasive presence had spread
itself through his body
and sought to possess itself of his
vital processes
i shuddered at the thought of those
vital processes
worn as they were by 81 years of
continuous functioning
in conflict with unknown forces of which
the youngest and strongest system might
well be afraid
but in another moment reflected that
dreams are only dreams
and that these uncomfortable visions
could be at most
no more than my uncle's reaction to the
investigations and expectations
which had lately filled our minds to the
exclusion of all else
conversation also soon tended to dispel
my sense of strangeness
and in time i yielded to my yawns and
took my turn at slumber
my uncle seemed now very wakeful and
welcomed his period of watching
even though the nightmare had aroused
him far ahead of his allotted two hours
sleep seized me quickly and i was at
once haunted with dreams of the most
disturbing kind
i felt in my visions a cosmic and
abysmal loneliness
with hostility surging from all sides
upon some prison where i lay confined
i seemed bound and gagged and taunted by
the echoing yells of distant multitudes
who thirsted for my blood
my uncle's face came to me with less
pleasant association than in waking
hours
and i recall many futile struggles and
attempts to scream
it was not a pleasant sleep and for a
second i was not sorry for the echoing
shriek which clothed through the
barriers of dream
and flung me to a sharp and startled
awakeness in which every actual object
before my eyes
stood out with more than natural
clearness and reality
i had been lying with my face away from
my uncle's chair
so that in this sudden flash of
awakening i saw only the door to the
street
the window and the wall and floor and
ceiling toward the north of the room
all photographed with morbid vividness
on my brain
and a light brighter than the glow of
the fungi or the rays from the street
outside
it was not a strong or even a fairly
strong light
certainly not nearly strong enough to
read an average book by
but it cast a shadow of myself in the
cot on the floor
and had a yellowish penetrating force
that hinted at things more potent than
luminosity
i perceived with unhealthy sharpness
despite the fact that two of my other
senses were violently assailed
for on my ears rang the reverberations
of that shocking scream
while my nostrils revolted at the stench
which filled the place
my mind as alert as my senses recognized
the gravely unusual
and almost automatically i leaped up and
turned about to grasp the destructive
instruments which we had left trained on
the moldy spot before the fireplace
as i turned i dreaded what i was to see
for the scream had been in my uncle's
voice
and i knew not against what menace i
should have to defend him and myself
yet after all the sight was worse than i
had dreaded
there are horrors beyond horrors and
this was one of those nuclei of all
dreamable hideousness which the cosmos
saves to blast an accursed and
unhappy few out of the fungus-ridden
earth steamed up a vaporous corpse light
yellow and diseased which bubbled and
lapped to a gigantic height and vague
outlines half human and half monstrous
through which i could see the chimney
and fireplace beyond
it was all eyes wolfish and mocking
and the rugose insect-like head
dissolved at the top to a thin stream of
mist
which curled putridly about and finally
vanished up the chimney
i say that i saw this thing but it is
only in conscious
retrospection that i ever definitely
traced its damnable approach to form
at the time it was to me only a seething
dimly phosphorescent cloud of fungus
loathsomeness
enveloping and dissolving to an
abhorrent plasticity the one
object on which all my attention was
focused
that object was my uncle the venerable
elijah whipple
who with blackening and decaying
features leered and jibbered at me
and reached out dripping claws to rend
me in the fury which this horror had
brought
it was a sense of routine which kept me
from going mad
i had drilled myself in preparation for
the crucial moment
and blind training saved me recognizing
the bubbling evil as no substance
reachable by matter
or material chemistry and therefore
ignoring the flamethrower which loomed
to my left
i threw on the current of the crook's
tube apparatus
and focus toward that scene of immortal
blasphemousness the strongest ether
radiations which man's art can arouse
from the spaces and fluids of nature
there was a bluish haze and a frenzied
sputtering and the yellowish
phosphorescence grew dimmer to my eyes
but i saw the dimness was only that of
contrast
and that the waves from the machine had
no effect whatever
then in the midst of that demonic
spectacle i saw a fresh horror which
brought cries to my lips
and sent me fumbling and staggering
toward that unlocked door to the quiet
street
careless of what abnormal terrors i
loosed upon the world
or what thoughts or judgments of men i
brought down upon my head
in that dim blend of blue and yellow the
form of my uncle had commenced a
nauseous liquefaction
whose essence eludes all description and
in which they're played across his
vanishing face
such changes of identity as only madness
can conceive
he was at once a devil in a multitude a
charnel house and a pageant
lit by the mixed and uncertain beams
that gelatinous face assumed a dozen
a score a hundred aspects grinning as it
sank to the ground on a body that melted
like tallow
in the caricatured likeness of legions
strange and yet not strange
i saw the features of the harris line
masculine and feminine
adult and infantile and other features
old and young
coarse and refined familiar and
unfamiliar
for a second there flashed a degraded
counterfeit of a miniature of poor mad
robie harris that i had seen in the
school of design museum
and another time i thought i caught the
raw boned image of mercy dexter
as i recalled her from a painting in
carrington harris's house
it was frightful beyond conception
toward the last when a curious blend of
servant and baby visages flickered close
to the fungus floor
where a pool of greenish grease was
spreading it seemed as though the
shifting features
fought against themselves and strove to
form contours like those of my uncle's
kindly face
i like to think that he existed at that
moment
and that he tried to bid me farewell it
seems to me i hiccuped a farewell from
my own parched throat
as i lurched out into the street a thin
stream of grease following me through
the door
to the rain-drenched sidewalk
the rest is shadowy and monstrous there
was no one in the soaking street
and in all the world there was no one i
dared tell
i walked aimlessly south past college
hill and the athenium
down hopkins street and over the bridge
to the business section
where tall buildings seem to guard me as
modern material things guard the world
from ancient
and unwholesome wonder then gray dawn
unfolded wetly from the east
silhouetting the archaic hill and its
venerable steeples
and beckoning me to the place where my
terrible work was still
unfinished and in the end i went
wet hatless and dazed in the morning
light
and entered that awful door in benefit
street which i had left a jar
and which still swung cryptically in
full sight of the early householders to
whom i dared not speak
the grease was gone for the moldy floor
was porous
and in front of the fireplace was no
vestige of the giant doubled up form
traced in nighter i looked at the cot
the chairs the instruments my neglected
hat
and the yellowed straw hat of my uncle
dazedness was uppermost
and i could scarcely recall what was
dream and what was reality
then thought trickled back and i knew
that i had witnessed things more
horrible than i had dreamed
sitting down i tried to conjecture as
nearly as sanity would let me
just what had happened and how i might
end the horror
if indeed it had been real matter it
seemed not to be
nor ether nor anything else conceivable
by mortal mind
what then but some exotic emanation some
vampirish vapor
such as exeter rustic's telev as lurking
over certain churchyards
this i felt was the clue and again i
looked at the floor before the fireplace
where the mold and nighter had taken
strange forms
in 10 minutes my mind was made up and
taking my hat i set out for home
where i bathed ate and gave by telephone
an order for a pickaxe
a spade a military gas mask and six
carboys of sulfuric acid
all to be delivered the next morning at
the cellar door of the shunned house in
benefit street
after that i tried to sleep and failing
past the hours in reading and in the
composition of inane verses to
counteract my mood
at 11am the next day i commenced digging
it was sunny weather and i was glad of
that i was still alone
for as much as i feared the unknown
horror i sought
there was more fear in the thought of
telling anybody
later i told harris only through sheer
necessity
and because he had heard odd tales from
old people which disposed him ever so
little toward belief
as i turned up the stinking black earth
in front of the fireplace
my spade causing a viscous yellow i-core
to ooze from the white fungi which it
severed
i trembled at the dubious thoughts of
what i might uncover
some secrets of inner earth are not good
for mankind
and this seemed to me one of them my
hand
shook perceptibly but still i delved
after a while standing in the large hole
i had made
with the deepening of the hole which was
about six feet square
the evil smell increased and i lost all
doubt of my imminent contact with the
hellish thing whose emanations had
cursed the house
for over a century and a half i wondered
what it would look like
what its form and substance would be and
how big it might have waxed through long
ages of life sucking
at length i climbed out of the hole and
dispersed the heaped up dirt
then arranging the great carboys of acid
around the near two sides
so that when necessary i might empty
them all down the aperture
in quick succession after that i dumped
earth only along the other two sides
working more slowly and dotting my gas
mask as the smell grew
i was nearly unnerved at my proximity to
a nameless
thing at the bottom of a pit suddenly my
spade struck something
softer than earth i shuddered and made a
motion as if to climb out of the hole
which was now as deep as my neck
then courage returned and i scraped away
more dirt in the light of the electric
torch i had provided
the surface i uncovered was fishy and
glassy
a kind of semi-putrid congealed jelly
with suggestions of translucency
i scraped further and saw that it had
form
there was a rift where a part of the
substance was folded over
the exposed area was huge and roughly
cylindrical
like a mammoth soft blue white stove
pipe doubled in two its largest part
some two feet in diameter
still more i scraped and then abruptly i
leaped out of the hole and away from the
filthy thing
frantically unstopping and tilting the
heavy carboys
and precipitating their corrosive
contents one after another
down that charnel gulf and upon the
unthinkable abnormality whose titan
elbow i had seen
the blinding maelstrom of greenish
yellow vapor which surged tempestuously
up from that hole as the floods of acid
descended
will never leave my memory all along the
hill
people tell of the yellow day when
virulent and horrible fumes arose from
the factory waste
dumped in the providence river but i
know how mistaken they are
as to the source they tell too of the
hideous roar which at the same time
came from some disordered water pipe or
gas main underground
but again i could correct them if i
dared
it was unspeakably shocking and i do not
see how i lived through it
i did faint after emptying the fourth
carboy which i had to handle after the
fumes had begun to penetrate my mask
but when i recovered i saw that the hole
was emitting no fresh vapors
the two remaining carboys i emptied down
without particular results
and after a time i felt it safe to
shovel the earth back into the pit
it was twilight before i was done but
fear had gone out of the place
the dampness was less fetid and all the
strange fungi had withered to a kind of
harmless grayish powder
which blew ash-like along the floor
one of earth's nether-most terrors had
perished forever
and if there be a hell it had received
at last the demon soul of an unhallowed
thing
and as i patted down the last spadeful
of mold
i shed the first of the many tears with
which i have paid unaffected tribute to
my beloved uncle's memory
the next spring no more pale grass and
strange weeds came up in the shunned
houses terraced garden
and shortly afterward carrington harris
rented the place
it is still spectral but its strangeness
fascinates me
and i shall find mixed with my relief a
queer regret when it is torn down
to make way for a tawdry shop or vulgar
apartment building
the barren old trees in the yard have
begun to bear small sweet apples
and last year the birds nested in their
gnarled boughs
you